they shelter behind rocks and under
tents pitched in mud these people have
fled fighting more than once they known
fear and desperation Camille tells me as
they bombed his house many fled here to
Italy province after being told they'd
be safe it's supposed to be a
de-escalation zone agreed by Russia Iran
and Turkey that just hasn't happened
this woman says her two nephews were
killed Homs everything is being attacked
she says tens of thousands have already
run away from this a fresh wave of
attacks and violence from the Syrian
regime forces and their first ground
offensive in italy' province in nearly
three years these pictures from a jihadi
rebel group claimed to show the fierce
fighting as the government attempts to
push inside
Eid Lib the provinces civil defense
group insists the regime is deliberately
and systematically attacking hospitals
and medical centers to try to force
people to flee many of those now being
attacked hurt and killed were those who
fled another hell in Aleppo thousands
are heading towards the Turkish border
with aid agencies busily trying to build
camps on the Syrian side but as more and
more try to find refuge away from the
fighting European politicians fear yet
another wave of migration some of these
people have moved several times before
it's wet it's in the middle of winter at
the moment they feel safe but how long
is that likely to last has nurse husband
was killed in a bomb strike when their
daughter was just five months old she's
been running ever since and living here
for the past 20 days all she wants is to
go back home with all sides talking
tough Turkey's sent extra troops into
the area to bolster its border with
Syria there are peace talks planned for
the end of the month but this latest
fighting threatens to jeopardize that
and the Syrian people caught in the
middle have long ago given up on getting
any real outside home Alex Crawford Sky
News in Italy province Syria